un torrencial sin fin en bangladesh
india fuertes lluvias provocaron
inundaciones que incomunicaron más de
100 aldeas y millones de personas muchas
zonas productivas se vieron afectadas
por el desbordamiento de dos importantes
ríos
vivimos poniendo una cama encima de otra
la mitad de nuestra finca está bajo el
agua si el agua sube no sabemos qué
haríamos mis aves del corral se murieron
no tengo ningún barco para traer comida
de otros lugares
no puedo recoger toda mi cosecha
conseguí cortar una sexta parte y
ponerle en sacos pero todos se
humedecieron por la lluvia el mes pasado
también perdí la cosecha anterior de
arroz es frustrante danko faixina en
ambas naciones las autoridades dan
cuenta de más de 50 fallecidos y dos
millones de personas atrapadas por las
inundaciones más fuertes en dos décadas
la crecida de los ríos del noreste de
india rompieron un importante dique en
el río barack que inundó a unos 100
poblados en taquilla donde ya reportan
desabastecimiento de comida y agua
faneite llevaba y recogemos el agua del
tejado para beber y para del banjo la
calamidad es insoportable la lluvia es
una bendición pero a la vez una
maldición
si bien las lluvias son frecuentes en
india y bangladesh los expertos afirman
que el cambio climático está aumentando
las posibilidades de fenómenos naturales
extremos en todo el mundo